welcome to afterward my name is Jonathan
Landay I'm the senior national security
correspondent for McClatchy Newspapers
and I'm here today with James Bamford to
talk about his new book the shadow
factory it's a book about the National
Security Agency the largest and most
secretive US intelligence agency it's
the agency that goes out and monitors of
communications all over the world
digging for intelligence of use to the
United States government he is the
author of two previous books
groundbreaking books on the National
Security Agency welcome to the show
thank you on my way over here I received
a press release from the American Civil
Liberties Union talking about how they
have filed Freedom of Information Act
requests with the Justice Department and
the National Security Agency of seeking
documents outlining their policies on
how they protect the privacy of US
person as they collect private US
citizens as they collect communications
and this was prompted this request was
prompted by revelations that were made
by two of the individuals who are in
your book can you talk about that yes
the way the NSA intercepts
communications these drops on
communications is by having people that
are largely in the military that sit at
listening posts and I have earphones on
and they listen to communications and
prior to 9/11 prior to the changes the
warrantless eavesdropping changes no
Americans were supposed to be listened
to any time an American came up in
communications they would be eliminated
from being listened to they would turn
the Machine off stop recording and so
forth and that's what one of the
intercept operators I interviewed told
me and then what she said was after 9/11
after the changes the Bush
administration's warrantless
eavesdropping program everything changed
and they began is dropping on American
citizens Americans talking to Americans
and recording transcribing and storing
all that information even though a lot
of it was just personal talk about home
finances or bedroom talk whatever and
that was what made the people I spoke to
very angry because first of all is of
what they felt was a violation of
law and secondly they felt they were
wasting time by eavesdropping on US
citizens having personal conversations
rather than trying to find terrorists
which is what they both went into the
military for and this ACLU lawsuit or
rather the ACLU press release I think
relates to that desire to get the actual
documents what is it that the the NSA
has that instructs these people what to
do when they pick up an American
communication now what we've heard since
the revelations of the NSA eavesdropping
on Americans without permission from the
court and this was in 2004 we've heard
countless assurances from both President
Bush from other senior people in the
administration both in the Justice
Department the former head of the NSA
general Hayden who is now the director
of the CIA that American Civil Liberties
Americans privacy's have been protected
this seems to indicate otherwise
well it seems to indicate actually the
opposite the not only not being
protected they're being exploited one of
the intercept operators I interviewed
said that when they got in salacious or
sexual conversations between husbands
and wives for example or soldiers in the
field and their girlfriends or whatever
girlfriends or boyfriends that they
would pass those conversations around in
the listening posts and say hey you got
to listen to this one and they're all
listed on each other's computers they
look like iTunes and so they would just
say click on number 37 and they all
listened to it and giggle and you know
people over there risking their lives
and fighting you know in a war I don't
think should be expected to have people
back in the US government here making
humorous comments or making jokes out of
their private lives one of the things
that one of the questions that all of
this raises at least in my mind is how
valuable has this program been since it
was it was put into place after 9/11 and
has been collecting who knows how many
how much
not just conversations bye - over the
telephone but emails and and various
other the data so called data mining
techniques were where it seems the
government goes in and grabs people's
personal files that are on the massive
computer databases both within the
government and private industry can how
successful has this been if at all in
actually ferreting out a active
terrorist terrorist and active terrorist
plots what haven't been very successful
there was a recent report that just came
out within a few weeks ago that I think
was from the Congressional Research
Service that showed that the data mining
that the government puts so much
emphasis on with the CIA Total
Information Awareness and lots of that
shifted over to NSA and this whole idea
of gathering everybody's receipts from
every time you go through a tollbooth
every time you see in a hotel to every
book you buy every all that you put it
all together and you find out who the
terrorists are what this report says is
it's nonsense it's sort of black magic
they make a lot out of it but nothing
comes from it and it was sort of similar
from talking to the intercept operators
one of the shocking things I felt found
was that in talking to one of them at
the major listening post again the major
listening posts for the Middle East this
is the one in Georgia it is in Georgia
it's a it's not in the Middle East it's
not anywhere in the area it's it's just
below the South Carolina border near
Augusta Georgia is hidden windowless
building wrapped around by by barbed
wire fences and this is the largest
listening post in the world right now as
far as NSA is eavesdropping goes but
what the intercept operators were saying
was that the quality of the intercepts
were extremely poor because the quality
of the of the process and getting these
intercepts was very poor because they
didn't have the right people speaking
the right languages one of the people
that was there until 2003 said that
during that entire time they didn't have
a single person that spoke costume which
is the principal language in Afghanistan
if you're going to go after the tell
this is the same time we went to war
with Afghanistan it would be nice if he
had somebody that spoke the language so
what they ended up doing was they
created a small little classier to teach
them but because Arabic and Pashtun were
so different from each other nobody
ended up learning anything from the
course the other thing was that a lot of
these people are taught the classical
Arabic the standard Arabic and not the
dialect so when they're put in this
position of eavesdropping they're not
really hearing the the language the way
they should be they're hearing the
language without the proper dialect and
one of the intercept operators said that
was an extremely difficult problem and
to give you an idea why this could be
such a dangerous problem not only here
but over in Iraq is that you get these
people and they're picking up
conversations and it's a holly talking
to his brother Muhammad and the person's
typing out this transcript and he's
saying I'll bring over the melons from
the garden tomorrow so then the person
sitting there eavesdropping on this who
doesn't really understand the dialogue
has never been out of the country and
it's not very familiar with the culture
it has to say is this really melons he's
talking about are these IEDs and if he
says IEDs and you know there's a good
chance that person's going to have a
bomb dropped on his house and his family
killed or they're going to be house
rated and the person put in Abu Ghraib
or something the person I talked to the
intercept operator said that was a given
in a nightmare that night thinking about
all the innocent people they may have
killed by putting a comment when they
have no idea they're half the world away
sitting listening to some conversation
between people they've never heard of
before and they're making life-and-death
decisions over whether the person is
telling the truth or whether they aren't
one of the scary things the questions
that was raised in this chapter of the
book that we're talking about and this
has to do with this system called the
Highlander system I believe is the idea
that that as you said earlier for injure
American journalists American soldiers
even American aid workers were being
targeted by this system their
conversations
courted and there's a there's a
suggestion here that one place that
where these people were staying was a
hotel that was subsequently hit by the
America the American military is the
allegation that perhaps this hotel was
hit as a consequence of it being
targeted by the NSA well that's a you
know it's an interesting question I can
give a definitive answer to it but what
it implies is that you have intercept
operators that were picking up
indications that this this hotel was
going to be targeted and the intercept
operators were telling their fellow
soldiers in the army that they you know
this is where all the journalists are
staying but it was hit anyway and those
are the dangers you've got you've got
people listening to these conversations
and whether the the proper actions are
taken after they listen to it you never
know and that was one of the things that
was you know just really enlightened to
me was the amount of information they
they were bringing in but the the lack
of real intelligence they were getting
out of all this information and so one
of the actually both of the lists both
of the intercept operators we're
complaining most about and is very hard
for having written three books now on
NSA and having done this since 1982 it's
very difficult to get somebody who
worked at NSA to come forward giving
their name and speaking publicly
especially on television now saying what
goes on because of all the pressure on
them never to say anything but here
these people came forward even though
they you know there's not only no
benefit there's potentially a lot of
deficit for them coming forward but they
felt very strongly that what they were
doing was wrong legal moral to some
degree and and just a waste of time and
money
now you say in the book that this
program was clearly illegal let's go
back to the basics about NSA what it was
set up to do and why the
eavesdropping on American citizens
without Wyatt without a court
authorization is illegal well under the
original Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Act which was established
in 1978 in order to prevent earlier
prevent abuses like had taken place
earlier part of that law said that if
you want to use drop on a US person you
have to get a warrant from a secret
court the secret quarters of Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Court what it
is is the court acts as a buffer between
NSA which does the eavesdropping and the
American citizens who were potentially
subjected to this so NSA wasn't allowed
to eavesdrop on u.s. citizens unless
they got the OK from a judge in the
court this is not a very difficult court
to get a warrant from in 30 years
they've issued some 20,000 approvals and
they've only issued about two or three
denials so it's a court that that is
easy for NSA to get the warrants that
they want to so bypassing the court
really made no sense to me right an NSA
was set up in the aftermath of world war
ii ii ii ii strop specifically on on
potential foreign enemies of the united
states is that correct oh sure it was
established following world war ii to
succeed the agencies in world war ii
that broke the japanese purple code and
the german enigma Enigma code and they
wanted to continue this through the Cold
War focusing on the Soviet Union and
they the NSA was formed in 1952
became a agency so secret that even
Congress wasn't told about it it's very
name was top secret
unlike the CIA which was formed through
Congress in a public law so NSA was
given the charge of basically listening
to foreign communications and basically
trying to find out when or if the Soviet
Union is about to launch a nuclear
attack this whole job was to prevent
another surprise attack like we had it
Pearl Harbor and communications back
then we're very different from what they
are today the way that the data is
carried around the world and it kind of
made NSA's jobs somewhat easier didn't
it when when back then a lot of most
Communications was was by satellite
that's right most throughout the 60s 70s
80s and throughout much of the 1990s the
main way that the United States have
received and sent international
communications was by satellite and that
was very beneficial for NSA because if
it wanted to eavesdrop on those
communications all it had to do which it
did do was build these large satellite
dishes one was in Sugar Grove West
Virginia another than the in Yakima in
the state of Washington and they pull in
all this communications from the
satellite and then put it through
computers and so forth and there was no
need to ever let the telecommunications
companies know about it because they
could do it with satellites hidden in
valleys that are unseen by or hidden
basically from the public that changed
in the late 90s because
telecommunication has changed instead of
going by satellite most communications
now international communications started
going by undersea cable and that's
because of the development of
fiber-optic communications that's where
the communications go through the cable
in the form of a light beam the photon
as opposed to an electron as opposed to
an electrical cable
you could fit far more capacity in there
and is far more reliable so the there
was a tremendous building boom I'm
putting these cables under the sea and
then communications companies using
those and that became a very big problem
for NSA because his communications
started drifting away from the
satellites and onto these undersea
cables and it's a had difficulty
collecting that information it left them
with only two options one that could put
a submarine down to tap the fiber-optic
cable and according to people I've
talked to they never had real success in
doing that and it'd be very difficult
and time
consuming anyway and we only have one
submarine that could do that so the
other alternative was to make secret
deals secret agreements with the telecom
companies and this isn't anything really
new this is the third time that the US
government has gone to telecom companies
and asked them to secretly turn over
their communications we did in 1920s we
did it
from the mid 40s up until 1975 when it
was discovered operation shamrock and
then shut down so they did it again the
idea was to go to the telecom company
you say that we need your help we need
to get into your private communication
systems and they agreed to it and what
happened after that was the NSA started
building these secret rooms inside the
telecom switches these are big buildings
without windows and major cities like in
San Francisco now what's interesting
about this I just finishing up the
documentary for Nova that I was working
on that sharing in January and we traced
the path of all these communications
around the world it's interesting
because most of the telecommunications
from the from Asia and the Pacific area
all come into the u.s. on this one Beach
in California and then they go up to
this little building about two miles
away and from there then they go to
other large switches 18t switches now if
you are going to if all you wanted was
the eavesdrop on international
communications just communications in
and out of the United States that's
where you would want to put your secret
room because that's where it all comes
in and where it all goes out but what
NSA did instead was they built it in
this large switch in downtown San
Francisco and that's not only where a
lot of the international communications
comes in it's where a lot of the
domestic community auditioning
everything so when when the cables all
come in to this one particular floor of
the building they're put through what's
known as a splitter box which is
basically a prism that separates the
photons and creates takes one photon and
basically creates
two of them out of the mirror image of a
fair image of the of the cable so one
cable the original cable continues on to
the proper communications networks in
the US and to the recipient and there's
this new cable clone cable a mirror
image cable that now goes to the next
floor below and into the secret room a
secret room that's controlled by NSA
this was revealed originally by mark
Klein who was one of the supervisors and
happened to see the room and got very
angry that the you know the US
government was testing there was a court
suit wasn't there against the company
that was doing that I mean he testified
that's right and the courts suit is
still in the final stages we probably
TNT it was a by the Electronic Frontier
Foundation against a pap and the suit
you know it was a very powerful suit had
eyewitnesses and so forth and I think it
probably would have been successful the
problem is the Congress in their
legislation last summer creating this
new amendments to the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Act made is
one of those amendments immunity for the
telecom companies so I don't think it's
been dismissed yet but it probably will
be dismissed soon although a EF f
Electronic Frontier Foundation decided
to file another suit hoping to find the
constitutionality of that immunity
grander in the lead up to writing about
all of this you start before 9/11 and
you take us through 9/11 and the NSA is
involved in history in that and then you
start talking about what it went and did
because it seems at least from what I've
read in the book and from what I've
myself reported on that that people in
the US government went overboard in
terms of their perception of the
al-qaeda threat the terrorists then
against the United States and and and
the idea that the president in time of
war has this overwhelming power
basically to do what he wants um but but
talked about before the situation just
before 9:00
eleven where you have this situation
where you have everything coming over
fiber-optic cables and yet the NSA had
managed to to locate this sort of
communication center in Yemen that Osama
bin Laden was using to coordinate his
network outside of Afghanistan they knew
where this place was they and they
actually had the names in their gigantic
database of at least one or both of the
men who were the sort of the main foot
soldiers in recruiting people and
carrying out the 9/11 attacks can you
talk about about that sure this is an
area that was fascinating to me because
the 9/11 Commission completely bypassed
looking at NSA which was extraordinary
to me since it's the largest
intelligence agency but they wanted to
focus primarily on on the CIA but what I
found was that prior to 9/11 the NSA had
been eavesdropping on bin Laden's
Operations Center which was his house in
Yemen and for this Nova documentary I'm
doing we actually went to Yemen and we
found the house that NSA was
eavesdropping on ese was eavesdropping
on this house bin Laden's operations
center for about three years and in
December of 1999 and if they picked up
this message sending these two people
Khalid and Nawaf to Kuala Lumpur for a
very secret meeting apparently it was
going to be a terrorist summit meeting
and NSA passed that information on to
the CIA and other agencies and they
began trying to find these people the
CIA had some surveillance on them but
they eventually lost them in when they
flew from Kuala Lumpur to Bangkok but
these people ended up back in the United
States the two terrorists were in the
United States as of January 2000
so the original two terrorists on the
9/11 plot first arrived in the United
States in California in January of 2000
they moved to San San Diego one of those
was Clete Alma Dart and he was married
to the husband I'm sorry he was married
to a woman who was living in the house
the command center in Yemen in Yemen so
he was communicating back and forth also
she was pregnant and he was wondering
about the you know when the baby's
coming and so forth so he's on the phone
calling back regularly the NSA is
intercepting a lot of these
communications they've got the time the
date they're actually picking up these
signals listening to these conversations
which are happening very frequently but
they're not telling anybody that these
people are in the United States they're
theirs and they're virtually not telling
anybody anything I interviewed the
person who was head of the bin Laden
unit at the CIA I interviewed him for
this Nova documentary and what he said
was that they were trying to get this
information from NSA you know what is it
that these people at the house are
saying what is it the people that mid
are and so forth is saying and all it
would get would be small summaries once
a week or something like that and
they're saying we need the actual
transfer baby but did they know that
these guys were actually in San Diego
they did anything everything they had
told them they not only never told them
they never gave them the transcripts of
the conversation it got so bad at the
head of the bin Laden unit at the CIA
had the CIA actually developed their own
intercept facility out in the Indian
Ocean I think it was on Madagascar the
secret intercept facility to intercept
the same communications from that house
the problem was you're only able to pick
up one half of the conversation probably
the downlink it was a downlink that they
got and so they went to NSA and they
said okay we're now able to get half the
conversations on our own but can you
give us the other half of the
conversation and if they still refused
they met with the head of operations at
NSA and they refused it got so bad that
the terrorists that were living in San
Diego eventually moved across country a
month before the the actual attack and
set up their their final command center
in the same town that NSA exists
narrowing
Laurel Maryland yeah
they were literally just about two or
three miles away on the other side of
the hideout in the book which I found
amazingly ironic and for a month the the
terrorists and the eavesdroppers were
living in the same town shopping at the
same Safeway they were sending their
messages of Kinkos or sending money back
to the Middle East at Safeway the same
time the NSA employees were there
working out next NSA employees at gos
gym and you can almost bend up in the
director's office at NSA a number of
times and from his window you could
almost see where that motel was that
they were staying at so it it's the
ultimate irony in 9/11 that you have the
terrorists living side by side with the
eavesdroppers and and this agency would
paying about eight billion dollars for
never told anybody where they were or
never tried to even look for them what I
also and then correcting some wrong but
but you have the director then of the
NSA Michael Hayden General Michael
Hayden longtime veteran intelligence
official in the middle of all of this
when he's seeing that they are in fact
picking up these conversations from
inside the United States says we got to
go dark we cannot collect this
intelligence anymore
I guess because he figured he had to
obey what then was the the the well was
still the FISA law that correct well he
was overcompensating for for what the
law was I remember interviewing him in
his office I think right around the same
time the terrorists were in San Diego
and he said at the time the only they
only had less than half a dozen they
were only eavesdropping on less than
half a dozen people in the US and I
don't think they even wanted to do those
the problem was NSA didn't have any
problem on energy there was no legal
problem prohibiting them from
eavesdropping on the 9/11 terrorists
first of all they knew they were
terrorists they were being sent from bin
Laden's Operations Center their names
have been in their computer for for some
time and you know the question is what
are they doing why are they here why
should they be
in the United States and all they would
have had to do was to go to the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Court would
have taken a day or so you know day or
so and they were here for almost could
leave then and also on an emergency
basis well Courtney days it could have
done it they kind of immediately started
listening to him the moment they came in
the United States I could have listened
to them the whole time they were here
almost two years and there would have
been no legal problem because all you
have to do to show the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Court is that
they're suspected terrorists because
they're being sent here by bin Laden
himself through his operation center and
the court itself is a very easy court
out of 20,000 or so a request they've
only turned down three or four two or
three or whatever so it is the bottom
line is they could have used dropped on
them without any legal problem that
chose not to and I think it was out of a
just basically over being overly careful
too careful
we're talking with investigative author
James Bamford about his new book the
shadow Factory and we will be back in a
minute afterwards and several other
c-span programs are available for
download as podcasts visit book TV Norg
more with James Bamford and Jonathan
Landay
in a moment on October 15th the National
Book Foundation announced the finalists
for the 2008 National Book Awards in
nonfiction the dark side the inside
story of how the war on terror turned
into a war on American ideals by Jane
Mayer this Republic of suffering death
and the American Civil War by drew
Gilpin Faust
the Hemings of the Monticello an
American family by an Ed gordon-reed
final salute a story of unfinished lives
by Jim Schuyler and the suicide index
putting my father's death in order by
john wickersham the winners of the 2008
National Book Awards will be announced
on November 19th afterwards with James
Bamford and Jonathan Landay continues
we're back with author James Bamford
talking about his new book the shadow
factory my name is Jonathan Landay I am
the national security correspondent for
McClatchy Newspapers we're talking about
how the NSA had in fact been tracking
two of the the chief hijackers the 9/11
hijackers while they're here in the
United States the head of the NSA
general Michael Gordon at that point
might say sorry
General Michael Hayden at that point
decides to overcompensate in terms of
the fact that NSA is not supposed to be
monitoring at least American citizens
inside the United States as you pointed
out he could in fact monitor foreign a
suspected terrorists inside the United
States simply by going through the
special court the federal sorry the
Foreign Intelligence Surveillance Court
and gotten permission to do this and yet
and yet didn't talk about the fact that
it seems that the CIA was also doing
their own investigation had also in fact
determined it close to the time when the
the attack actually took place that
these guys were in the United States
well the CIA also dropped the ball
because the the CIA picked up original
originally they picked up the
information that these guys had visa or
at least clean emitter had a visa for
the United States who was coming to the
United States that information went to
the CIA virtually immediately right
after that conversation in Yemen in
December 1999 January they flew to kuala
lumpur and at that time the CIA found
out that Klayton mid r was from they are
basically going to come to the United
States the problem was when that
information arrived at the CIA's bin
Laden unit a place called Alex station
it's the name of it
two of the FBI agents in there and I
interviewed one of those two FBI agents
two FBI agents have been assigned to
that unit and marchesini was one of them
and I interviewed him he'd never been
interviewed before and even the 911
Commission never interviewed him and
what he said was that he and his partner
Doug Miller wanted to notify the FBI
immediately that these guys were on the
way to the United States they had a visa
for the United States
Dilys pedometer and in midair was a
suspected terrorist sent by the laden's
Operations Center
but when Doug Miller typed up the the
memo
the FBI refute I'm sorry the CIA head of
the bin Laden unit refused to allow that
memo would to be sent to the FBI
headquarters and then when Mark was seen
II went up to say you know what's going
on here how come we can't send this this
memo to the FBI headquarters got a guy
coming to the US and the deputy head of
that unit the person that he was talking
to from that unit said listen the next
attack is going to take place in
Southeast Asia it's not going to take
place in the United States so when we
want the FBI to know about it we'll tell
the FBI about it until then you know the
memo was not going to go out as a result
of that the FBI was never notified had
the FBI been notified then they could
have quickly put the word out at the
entry points given it to the State
Department that put on their watchlist
mid our in-house me would never have
come or if they did come
the FBI definitely could have been
watching them and then tap their
telephone and found out you know once
they did that then they would have found
out about Muhammad auda and everybody
else so it was a number of very tragic
mistakes this CIA made a very tragic
mistake the NSA made a very tragic
mistake the difference is the 9/11
Commission never bothered to look into
the NSA's role in this whole 9/11 now
the NSA was picking up what you call
chatter what's in the business is called
chatter and it's increasing in tone and
severity The Closer you're getting we're
getting to 9/11 and everybody is putting
out
in terms of the FBI and the CIA they're
all putting out these these threat
notices these warnings and yet what
happened why they don't seem to be
talking to each other they don't see the
NSA seems to be not directing the being
specific in terms of the warning notices
it's putting out and and yet there were
these indications that something was
about to happen
well the biggest indication something
was about to happen came because a as he
had done several times before I've been
Laden called in a reporter it was in
June it was a reporter from Middle East
one of the Middle East television
services and although bin Laden didn't
talk to himself he was there and his
deputies told him that something big was
going to be happening soon as soon as
that news got out there was chatter all
over the Middle East something's going
to happen and you know the US
intelligence community knew the pattern
once bin Laden sort of said something
like that within a few months something
bad is going to happen that's what
happened with the coal and the and also
the attacks on East Africa both of which
and as I missed and I say missed both of
those also so NSA is getting very
panicky they're hearing these warnings
coming constantly but they don't know
what's going to happen or where it's
going to happen and that's nice guys
meanwhile we're about two miles away
from NSA headquarters at that moment
during a lot of that they were living on
the other side of the bottom of
Washington Parkway from the NSA
headquarters and one point the the
director of NSA is told that these guys
that finally at the last minute maybe a
few weeks before 9/11 two or three weeks
before 9/11 the FBI finally gets the
information from the CIA that these guys
are now in the United States so NSA is
looking all over for I mean they had the
sort of panicking meeting the same
weekend Mohammed auda is having his
final he had two final summit meetings
in that same town
and one of them was the weekend before
the attack so and one one of those
meetings they had to rent 303 motels in
order to have everybody there and again
all this is taking place literally on
the other side of the highway from from
NSA and then on the the final the day
before the attack the hijackers climb in
their car and drive to Dulles Airport
and stay in a motel there the day before
the attack so it I would never see their
also continuing to intercept they have
two final two two very loud messages
that they've intercepted that seem to
indicate something's going to happen
tomorrow is zero hour and and the match
begins tomorrow and these are
conversations that they've picked up
between Afghanistan and Saudi Arabia
right from parts of Afghanistan that
were they knew that bin Laden's people
were so they picked those up they came
in on on they actually intercepted them
and got him into NSA headquarters on
September 10th the day before the attack
but nobody bothered to read those until
after the attack on September 11th and
then nobody sent them out to anybody
until September 12th so a similar thing
happened during World War two where the
warning message of the Japanese was
intercepted before the attack and they
translated it the predecessor to NSA
translated it and found you know
basically determined an attack was soon
going to happen they didn't know where
and they sent it out and the day of the
attack at Pearl Harbor that afternoon
after the attack was over a little
messenger comes up with with the with
the memo from from Washington saying
there's an attack that might happen so
you have this ironic tragedy happening
all over again so there's some pretty
dramatic scenes that you also put in the
book and one is about it has sort of
what's happening at NSA as the attacks
are taking place and and it turns out
that the
Michael Hayden thinks that perhaps his
own agency is going to be a target of
the hijackers what does he do well first
of all NSA is located halfway between
Washington and Baltimore and it's
outside of the Washington complex and
it's a it's hidden from the road it's a
very very secret agency hidden from the
road and if you look at it I've been
through NSA a number of times a few
journalists has been given tours of it
for over a number of years and it's very
intimidating they have all kinds of
barriers all kinds of fences barbed wire
guards and everything the only problem
is if you come in over all that it makes
no difference and NSA was sitting there
like a huge glass Insurance Complex and
Hayden was afraid that the one of the
planes is going to hit the NSA and wipe
out completely wipe out NSA so he
ordered a complete evacuation of NSA and
everybody left the building except for a
small cadre of people one of the people
that couldn't leave were the the
counterterrorism people and they were in
one of the top floor you have this flow
of people he's just emptying this
high-security complex and there there's
traffic jams now trying to get to the
highway after everybody's leaving I mean
it to me it sounded a you know it's like
Pearl Harbor happening and then
everybody going home from the from the
Defense Department but you know he was
afraid that they were going to be
attacked evacuate the building but then
what was surprising he kept everybody
away for the next two days so the next
two days he only had a skeleton crew at
NSA and which you know I think would
surprise a lot of people that you know
here we are being attacked is the worst
worst attack since Pearl Harbor to
something even worse than Pearl Harbor
more deaths and everybody's being sent
home that happened at CIA also everybody
was sent home let me one of the
questions that came up for me as I read
the book in this part was you had let's
go back to what you had described
earlier where Hayden
seems seemingly overcompensated for what
he thought were the requirements to
preserve privacy even though the guys
who were listening to were actually
suspected terrorists and whose names are
already in the NSA database and you have
the attack happen and then after the
attack you see this this incredible
expansionist explosion in in NSA's
monitoring and what it was doing in
terms of eavesdropping not just overseas
but here in the United States and I
thought to myself is it possible that
having undergone and and one of the
things you point out is that that one of
the things that Hayden did was start
actually listening to conversations in
the United States with people overseas
without before he even gets authorized
to do this by the Justice Department by
the White House is this a case of hating
having overcompensated one way feels
guilty
feels like perhaps because of the
oversights and the bureaucratic knots
that they were tied in that he now has
to go he decides he's going to go the
other way and overcompensate on the side
of violating privacy violating civil
liberties well I think so I think that's
a good analysis of it and I think the
that's probably what happened he knew
immediately on September 11th what had
happened because he'd been aware of the
names
clida mid-iron Waffle House me because
they had been looking for them for for
the last few weeks in the United States
and they had them as you say in their
database for years so all of a sudden I
think on September 11th or maybe
September 12th their their names
appeared in the press as being the the
people response and they've been in this
NSA database for what three years at
least three years yeah and not only that
then they they knew they were in the US
at that point and whether that at that
point they realized how far they
you know they were just over the other
side of the highway I don't know but the
it was something that the NSA should
have known because if you just pick up a
telephone you can see you know
somebody's calling you from California
or they're calling you from Maryland so
realizing that they very much blew it
these are the guys that they have been
listening to and here it is these are
the guys in the track had tracked it
some have been tracking for years right
and had numerous intercepts and these
are the guys that the whose intercepts
they refused to give to the CIA so yeah
I think that there was this all of a
sudden this enormous feeling of chagrin
that you know holy mackerel look what
would happen and look who these guys
were so there's a this emphasis to do
the opposite to go the opposite extreme
and that in general Hayden had always
been a very ambitious general working
his way up by he wasn't one of the
people who went to the Air Force Academy
he he's sort of an unlikely person to
get into that position he he went to not
any of the service schools and he didn't
study anything technical he wouldn't got
a bachelor's and master's degree in
history so all of a sudden now he's
three-star general head of the NSA and
having been with him a number of times
men on the number of times in or his
house for dinner
I got the sense that he he really had
this this feeling of both ambition and
also deference to powerful people so he
was in a perfect he was sort of the
perfect person for Dick Cheney to come
to and say okay you got to expand this
tremendously now yeah wasn't it Hayden
who actually did that first he goes to
me I was yeah he's listening to this he
starts dropping what you call
minimization what they call minimization
of their intercepts between Afghanistan
and I guess it's in the United States
and and minimization is what what
minimization means if you find out
you're listening to an American that you
immediately turn it off and if you
recorded anything you erase it and you
don't do any transcription you don't put
the person's name in the
yeah in the communication a u.s.
person's name in but he stops doing he
stops at unilaterally on his own on his
own and this is the beginning of what
eventually became known as the terrorist
surveillance program exactly and so he
started doing it on his own and again
out of this feeling of I blew it before
the attack you know I'm going to make up
for it after the attack so he
unilaterally decides to begin he's
dropping and dropping the minimization
rules which is part of the law I mean
this isn't an option this is part of the
law and then Cheney calls him for a
meeting and Cheney acid what more can
you do and then he says well there's
laws against it but I can begin he's
dropping on America holic Hayden packing
with the political wind yeah I mean
that's what he did and when I was with
me he told me once the sir boasted that
he had went to a baseball game with
Condoleezza Rice you know he was glowing
when he told me that and and so he he
has his deference towards senior
officials when he should have been
having a deference to what the laws were
in the statutes and so forth so he
agreed to to do that and ironically the
the administration was telling him go
ahead and do it you got all the legal
power and his lawyers were saying okay
where is the legal power and the Justice
Department was saying we can't wash out
we can't show you you're not cleared for
your agencies can do all this demand yet
so publicly Hayden is saying he's
comfortable that they're not violating
the Fourth Amendment the protection to
privacy and the Phi sac but his lawyers
are saying go ahead and do it it's fine
he's saying his lawyers are giving him
the go-ahead yet his lawyers haven't
even gotten the official word from the
Justice Department as to how you could
violate the law I mean this is a statute
and what a lot of people don't realize
is the Foreign Intelligence Surveillance
Act it's not a civil statute it's a
criminal statute statute Congress in
1978 put teeth in it to prevent people
like President Nixon who
who had originally been the target of
this legislation to prevent him from
doing the eavesdropping
they put teeth in it making it a
criminal statute punishable by five
years in prison for every violation
which means every time it's it's done
every target you do illegally so it
shouldn't be just an easy thing to say
oh I don't know what the law is but I'll
buy a tit I mean there should be penalty
and this seems to fit in with the
political ideology that existed at the
time within the particular vice
president Cheney's office you quote his
top aide David Addington who's at the
heart of a lot of the Polly --gel Mathis
legally justified the abuse of detainees
the the Guantanamo Bay detainee program
the use of as they call them you know
the aggressive interrogation procedures
saying that you have him saying that he
and Cheney had always wanted to get rid
of the FISA Court they saw it as a
restraint on presidential prerogative
exactly they wanted the the court acted
as a buffer between NSA and the public
and they wanted to get rid of that
buffer so that all the decisions weren't
made by independent judges who knew a
lot about the law they were made by
Cheney and Hayden and Addington and Bush
and Addington really considered himself
the father or the the person who was the
designer of this warrantless
eavesdropping program again you have
somebody who was never elected somebody
who doesn't even want his picture taken
and making enormous decisions about
violating the laws and it's okay because
we're doing it the president has this
inherent power to eavesdrop on people
this is a very scary time and as you
brought up this wasn't just
eavesdropping it was the torture in
Guantanamo and Jonathan Turley who's one
of the
lead leading legal lights on this whole
issue professor george washington
university said that the what these
whistleblowers i've talked to said was
sort of the surveillance equivalent of
abu ghraib was the this is that much in
terms of significance how how badly the
the US laws and constitutions were
violated by this these changes these
warrantless changes in the law so then
you had as a consequence of this change
you had this massive expansion in in in
NSA eavesdropping and and and it extends
beyond the united states of course the
united states works with four other
countries four allied countries to do
eavesdropping around the world and it
was a program first called echelon i
believe and then subsequently expanded
you talk about one instance here and we
read earlier talked about how successful
this had been this program had been in
in finding terrorists you talk about
this this one incident in which a very
senior al-qaeda member is assassinated
as he drives in his in a vehicle i guess
it was in yemen was it oh yeah talk
about how that at least seems to be an
NSA one of the few NSA successes as a
result of this program well yeah and
this put this had nothing to do with the
warrantless eavesdropping on US citizens
in the u.s. but it does show the how NSA
achieved a success in getting rid of an
al-qaeda member and what happened was
that it shows you how NSA operates also
technologically there's this car riding
in a very rural area of yemen and in a
desert away from anything NSA was after
this one terrorists and they knew his
they had a couple NSA people assigned
specifically he was one of the people
that they were specifically listening
for
and they had a lot of his telephone
numbers satellite telephone numbers and
he hadn't used a satellite phone very
often but all of a sudden a little light
went off a little buzzer went off at NSA
that that phone was being used and they
listened to the conversation and the NSA
intercept operator knew this guy's voice
because he heard numerous conversations
from I mean heard tapes of his
conversations and although it was his
phone he didn't hear his voice and and
so he listened kept listening to it and
then all of a sudden there was a voice
from the backseat of the car he says
that's him
I was only like seven seconds that voice
in the backseat the backseat person the
backseat said something like don't take
a right take a left over here and go to
the other go down the road five miles or
something so then that was all being
tape-recorded and the NSA analysts then
brought a partner over but I thought a
co-worker over who also knew the voice
and he he also said yeah that's him
because they needed to to people to
confirm the the sound of the voice the
identity of the voice and and after that
the analysts notified the CIA which had
a this was operating drones from Dubai
this country nearby and nearby Yemen and
at the time the CIA and Dubai had a
drone nearby over that same part of the
desert in Yemen and within about 20
minutes they located the the car through
geo-positioning of finding out where the
signal was coming from it of the phone
it was it the suryya did it have the
unit's the kind of foam that it could
have been either a three or it could
have been a but you have a GPS you have
a geo-positioning signal that's right
yeah the NSA is very good at
geo-positioning the locations of phones
because they're picking up the signal
from multiple locations and they're able
to triangulate where those signals are
coming from
so as the drones flying over the CIA
pushes a button and the drone fires two
Hellfire missiles at the
car and completely destroyed it and and
I think there were five or six occupants
ironically one of the occupants was a an
American who had gone to Afghanistan and
join bin Laden's group so that I mean
that is how NSA could work if NSA is
going after terrorists and one of the
complaints I had was from the
whistleblowers I spoke to was that
that's the kind of thing they should be
doing why are why are we wasting our
time focused listening to soldiers talk
to their wives or their husbands rather
than I was one of those journalists over
there with her ayah with RIT with a
satellite phone and I read this story
book I'm thinking you know do they have
me calling my office do they have me
calling my wife to talk about you know
where I am because he was somewhat
worried I spent four months inside of
Iraq a book good chance to hear
communication to pick up then and I mean
just to use you for example then when
and to show how this was being targeted
this is just accidental the first time
it comes in it's a big funnel of all
this communication comes in and your
conversation like lots of others come in
to this to this funnel and that's where
these intercept operators sit and they
have these computers and each one has
this what they call cue it's a list of I
mean a long list of phone calls that
have come in and been recorded sometimes
just within a minute of the time they
were made they get the the phone call
and they're listening to these calls and
now they have an option they hear you
talking to your wife they you know
there's no sense of paying attention to
it it could push a button and that
number would be eliminated from so they
can't listen to me anymore you live in
me because armory would just say that
you know they're only picking up so much
so from now on all these calls from you
to home would not be listened to anymore
so then the next column the queue might
not be you but it might be the guy in
Yemen right and but they were told they
tried several
to get their commanding officer there
personally reporting to to say look you
know what I just erased these numbers
they're not you know useful numbers to
follow and they were told they have to
pick up everything and keep doing it so
once they leave that number in there
then from then on part of that so yeah
it's like sort of like a you know your
cell phone they're very used and that
name can definitely pop up and it will
continually be brought in at that point
that phone call your phone calls are
being targeted because your number is
deliberately being left into the system
to be eavesdropped on and the the other
bad aspect of that is that there is no
erasing afterwards so it goes into
stored it's stored forever and they're
building this brand new facility in
Texas to store they've run out of room
at NSA NSA's secret city and in Fort
Meade so they're actually building this
big storage facility of warehouse let me
know there's a lot we haven't covered in
the book but I want to talk about the
end because this goes straight to it you
raised the potential because they have
so much of this data that they could
actually use this data the government
can use this data to basically do away
with our civil liberties can quickly
sort stalk about that we've got a very
few seconds left sure once this
information in there is in there forever
and if you get some president in like
Richard Nixon who wants to use that
information for political reasons all
you have to do is put the name in there
he'll get it out if somebody wants to
use it for blackmail they can get it out
because it's stored there forever and
it's easily accessible and it's a huge
warehouse full of these conversations so
Congress saw obviously needs to do there
needs to be some kind of new safeguards
well the problem with Congress is they
were rushed into the first warrantless
eavesdropping bill and then they sort of
rushed into the second one and they
really need to do something about it
well James thanks very much for for
talking about your new book it's the
shadow factory by James Bamford I'm
Jonathan Landay a senior national
security correspondent with